in a shock move Republican Speaker of
the House Paul Ryan will be retiring
Mark Zuckerberg gets grilled on the hill
and the Trump investigation continues to
proceed I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
so this week is crazy lots of stuff
happening this week the FBI raids the
presidents of the United States
personals lawyer personal lawyer's
office
two days ago and now the Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan announces that he will
not be running up for re-election and
that he will in fact step down from his
position as Speaker after the November
elections and that he will not run for
reelection meaning he will leave office
in January of 2019 that is a major
development plus Mark Zuckerberg goes to
the hill and gets it grilled in historic
fashion but before we get to any of
those things first I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Lending Club so
we all need a helping hand sometimes the
reality is sometimes you just need a
little bit of money whether it's
unexpected repairs or medical expenses
or credit card debt and that's where
Lending Club comm comes in so Lending
Club gives you access to low rates on
loans of up to 40,000 bucks for almost
any purpose it's easier than going to a
bank and it offers lower rates than high
interest credit card so what you do is
you go to Lending Club com you enter how
much money you need and you can see if
you are approved in minutes and then you
pick the offer that is right for you and
the money can be in your accounts in
just a matter of days it is that simple
for more than 10 years Lending Club has
helped millions of people with over
thirty 1 billion dollars in loan so
right now go to Lending Club comm slash
Bend you can check your rate for free it
will not impact your credit score which
is great Lending Club calm slash bad
Lending Club calm slash Ben all loans
made by web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender and again this is a great
place to go if you are just looking for
a mid-range loan that is not going to
cost you an arm and a leg the way that a
credit card loan would and that you need
on short notice you don't have to go
through the entire Bank process that you
might have to go to if you went to the
bank for a different sized loan instead
you go to Lending Club comm and they
help you get access to low rates on
loans of up to $40,000 again its Lending
Club comm slash Ben and you can check
your rate for free right now use that
slash Ben so they know that we sent you
all right so the big breaking news on
this Wednesday is that Speaker of the
House of Paul Ryan has announced that he
will indeed be stepping down from his
position as Speaker of the House now
he's not going to do that until after
the election he also will not be running
for reelection in his district he
announced it this morning and here is
what it sounded like you realize
something when you take this job
it's a big job with a lot riding on you
and you feel it but you also know that
this is a job that does not last forever
you realize that you hold the office for
just a small part of our history so you
better make the most of it it's fleeting
and that inspires you to do big things
and on that score I think we have
achieved a heck of a lot okay so you
know Paul Ryan is of course going to say
that because he's leaving the truth is
that Paul Ryan has achieved some things
he has not achieved others his great
dream was entitlement reform he thought
that he was gonna be able to save the
country from the oncoming train that is
Social Security Medicare and Medicaid
collapse which will be happening over
the next 10 to 20 years that didn't
happen he did get tax cuts passed that's
a good move he was able to pass through
revocation of the individual mandate
which is obviously a good thing there
he's been able to get rid of some of the
regulations that the Obama
administration put in place through the
Congressional review act process he's
gotten a lot of flack as well and I have
a lot of thoughts on why it is that
speaker Ryan is going but first I think
we ought to review exactly what speaker
Ryan was because today you're gonna hear
a lot of people who are on the right
celebrating Paul Ryan going suggesting
the Paul Ryan going is gonna change the
way the Congress does business he was a
milquetoast he needs to go now listen I
don't think Paul Ryan ran everything as
well as things could be run how could
you
the man cut deals with patty Murray when
he was when he was not Speaker of the
House and then he cut a deal with
Democrats to to pass a 1.3 trillion
dollar omnibus package that there is no
excuse for passing but it is important
to note that for all of the bad bills
the Paul Ryan passed he also passed a
good bill that was rejected by Mitch
McConnell so I think a lot of the ire
that's been directed at Paul Ryan really
ought to be directed at Mitch McConnell
because here's how the process works
Paul Ryan would pass a very conservative
bill through a conservative house and
then it would go to the Senate and there
it would die and then Mitch McConnell
would pass a different version of a bill
and now the question was on Paul Ryan do
you steady stand fast do use helmets
McConnell that you're not gonna pass
anything the Senate passes do you tell
President Trump they're not gonna pass
something that he wants to sign or do
you go along to get along take the hit
on behalf of Mitch McConnell and now
you're seen as somebody who believes the
same things that Mitch McConnell
believes on spending and believes the
same things in terms of fiscal
priorities the president Trump does if
Paul Ryan can be faulted for anything
it's that he didn't hold Mitch
McConnell's and president Trump's feet
to the fire but let's be real about this
the same people who think that meant
that Paul Ryan is indeed a milquetoast
and a weakling would have been fighting
angry at him if President Trump had
gotten things on his desk they wouldn't
blamed Ryan anyway so in order of
priority for people who have not gotten
Trump's legislative agenda passed it
goes like this
Trump at the top of the list because he
has not had a solid legislative agenda
that has been pushed by the White House
in any serious way the turn over at the
White House has been too high the
turnover on topics has been too high the
president has not used his bully pulpit
to actually stump for legislation in any
real in serious way and he hasn't really
been part of the negotiations so the
buck stops with Trump this second on the
totem pole in terms of blame has to be
Mitch McConnell because Mitch McConnell
is the one with 51 senators and he's
been unable to get seriously
conservative legislation through the
Senate a third on the list is Paul Ryan
and yet people seem to have reversed
this polarity people seem to believe
that Paul Ryan is the real problem here
when he really is not and Mitch
McConnell is second on the list and that
Trump of course can never be blamed for
anything because we can't blame the
President of the United States when his
legislative agenda doesn't get passed so
how much of this is on Ryan I think some
is I think a lot is not second of all
it's important to note who is going to
take Paul Ryan's place so maybe it'll be
some money from the freedom caucus maybe
it'll be somebody who is more overtly
bloviating than than Paul Ryan Paul Ryan
is pretty polite guy maybe it'll be
somebody who's a more compelling speaker
more charismatic leader than Paul Ryan
and I would suggest that that's gonna
have to be the case because the high
likelihood is that the Republicans are
gonna lose the house in 2018 which means
that it had better be somebody who's a
fighter it better be somebody who's
going to try and obstruct Nancy Pelosi
agenda as much as humanly possible
considering the great likelihood is that
Paul Ryan will be succeeded as Speaker
not by another Republican but by Nancy
Pelosi which is a frightening thought in
all of its various permutations but the
person who replaces Paul Ryan you have
to wonder whether that person is really
gonna do a lot better than Paul Ryan
given the fact that Paul Ryan did not do
worse than John Boehner he did not do
worse than Jenny Hastert's he did not do
worse than late-stage Newt Gingrich to
be frank so all of the talk about Paul
Ryan being in the world's crap you
speaker I think is untrue I think that
he was the world's best speaker no I
also don't think he was temperamental he
cut out for the job I don't think Paul
Ryan wanted the job and I'm having met
Paul Ryan now I don't think that Paul
Ryan is is somebody who was fit for the
job because to be a good speaker of the
house requires a couple of things one
you either have to be a very canny
manipulator you have to be a Tip O'Neill
type you know the Democrat from the
1980s who manipulated his own members
manipulated Republicans
in order to get his agenda passed you
have to be very good at manipulating
people and fitting pieces together you
have to be more of a Mitch McConnell
temperament as sort of a turtle who's
able to slowly walk the legislation
through your house of Congress that was
not Paul Ryan or you have to be a great
visionary leader somebody who's
charismatic and who has an agenda that
is backed by your own caucus that was
mmm like Newt Gingrich in 1994 or Nancy
Pelosi in 2006 somebody who came in with
a whole list of agenda items that the
caucus agreed on and you could pass
those into law as fast as humanly
possible Paul Ryan obviously did not
have that sort of cohesion inside his
own caucus and he is also not a
particularly charismatic leader he's not
somebody who stands up and people say I
want to follow that guy into battle Paul
Ryan just was not suited for the job the
reason that Paul Ryan is announcing that
he's leaving right now there are a
couple of reasons one is because he
wants to spend more time with his family
but he could have announced this after
the election he could have waited until
after the election then announced listen
I'm not gonna be speaker anymore so I'm
leaving and I'm not interested in
running for reelection
I want to go home where I want my family
moved to Washington DC and I'll work for
American Enterprise Institute or
something
the reason they denounced this now is
twofold one Ryan knows that this blue
wave is coming ok the indicators are
very good the Democrats win the house
and it is quite possible they win the
Senate as well and the truck Schumer is
the new Senate Majority Leader and that
Nancy Pelosi is the new House Majority
Leader that she's the new Speaker of the
House rather and that sets up a really
bad cycle for going into 2020 which I'll
talk about in just a minute but if you
look at the list of Republicans who have
left hey it's a pretty sleng the-- list
of Republicans who are retiring this
term because they don't want to exist in
the Nancy Pelosi Congress ok trey Gowdy
is out Bob Goodlatte jeb Hensarling
rodney Frelinghuysen darrell Issa Lamar
Smith Ileana ros-lehtinen ret Lehtonen
charlie dent Dave record Pat's Barry
Franklin Lobby Ando Lynn Jenkins sam
johnson john duncan ted poe Dave Trott
Ryan Costello Bill Shuster Gregg Harper
Tom Rooney okay that's a list of
Republicans in the house who are
retiring this term and that doesn't
include the ones who are retiring
because of various scandals
there's a Republican in Pennsylvania who
retired over sex scandal there's a
Republican in Texas Blake Farenthold
who's retiring over a sex scandal okay
there are a lot of Republicans stepping
down because what they see is that the
polls don't look good so if you're Paul
Ryan and you're figuring okay we're in
serious trouble here right then we're
probably gonna lose the house and it's
really not because of Paul riding
they're gonna lose the house okay if
they lose the house the high likelihood
is because the President of the United
States has incredibly low approval
ratings and because Democrats hate him
with a passion equal to the fiery
burning passion and hatred of a thousand
suns okay they they hate President Trump
and that means that they're gonna show
up in November so if you're Paul Ryan
here's what you don't want you lose in
November and then everybody turns around
they say it's your fault Paul writes
your fault that you lost why would you
even take why would you bother sticking
around for that why would you bother
doing that instead Paul Ryan is saying
listen I'll keep fundraising but this
isn't this is not on me and I'm not the
one who has a 42 percent approval rating
in a time of a booming economy and no
serious Foreign Wars in the offing right
that's that's not me so I think that
Brian is making a political move and
that's why he is making the statement
now also he says and I think this is
probably true he doesn't want to lie to
his constituents about who's gonna serve
out his term because if he wins
re-election in November in his district
which he likely would and then retires
in January then he's been fibbing to his
constituents all along is to live with
those people so I think there's
something there as well
now the rumor that's going around is the
Ryan is leaving because Trump sort of
defeated Ryan I don't see this at all
it's important to recognize here that
trumps signal achievements have largely
been outside of the move of the of the
US Embassy to Jerusalem they've been
done because of Paul Ryan in Mitch
McConnell my tax cuts were a Paul Ryan
baby the revocation of the individual
mandate that was a Ted Cruz baby in the
the Justice Gorsuch and the end the
congressional the congressional approval
of Donald Trump's judicial nominees that
is Mitch McConnell so for all the talk
about Paul Ryan standing the way of
Trump's agenda there's really no
evidence that Paul Ryan has been
standing in the way of Trump's agenda in
fact it's been Paul Ryan trying to pass
Trump's agenda and he just can't get it
through the Senate because he's not a
senator he's not the Senate Majority
Leader I will say however that it's
pretty clear that Ryan leaving does
represents a triumph of trumpian
attitude now people have been mistaking
the gaps in policy between Trump and
Ryan for the serious gap that is not the
serious gap in the Republican Party
right now the serious gap in the
Republican Party is the gap between
attitudes now people have seen this is a
binary choice between Paul Ryan's sort
of polite wonk ashiness and Donald
Trump's punch everything including the
baby right these are the two choices you
can either wheel around you can tweet
whatever you want you can you can be
wild and crazy
and bombastic and that's the way you
ought to approach politics or you can be
milquetoast and Jack Kemp like in your
approach to politics I don't think
that's correct I think there is a middle
ground where you are very aggressive
when you need to be very aggressive and
you are polite when that possibility is
available you know it's something that I
try to pursue in my own sort of
political rhetoric but if the Republican
Party had to choose one it's pretty
clear that the base chose trumpian
rhetoric over Paul Ryan's rhetoric
because they are very angry and they're
very angry because they're very
frustrated and they're very frustrated
because no matter how many Republicans
they elect it seems that their agenda is
never passed and they can blame that on
Paul Ryan but the truth is that Paul
Ryan is just the head of the caucus I
promise you that Paul Ryan were the head
of a caucus that we're all freedom
caucus guys then the agenda would look
very different okay more thoughts on
Paul Ryan in just a second first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
bull and branch so you haven't been
getting enough sleep and you think that
it's because the temperature in the room
isn't right or you think it's because
your mattress isn't right well have you
ever thought that maybe just maybe it
might be the sheets that you're sleeping
then you don't tend to think about the
sheets the sleep on very often because
who thinks about sheets right who gives
a sheet but the fact is that bowl and
branch ensures that you have the best
sheets possible ball and branch these
sheets are just incredible they're 100%
organic cotton there are three
ex-presidents sleeping on them after I
got Bo and branch eats legitimately had
to throw out all the other sheets in my
house and buy only bowl and bran shoots
because they are that good they are that
comfortable and to get you started right
now you get 50 bucks off your first set
of sheets at bull and branch calm promo
code Ben that's bull and branch calm
promo code Ben again they make
everything from bedding to blankets and
it's made from pure 100% organic cotton
so they start out soft and they get even
softer over time you buy directly from
them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices a really nice set of
sheets can cost like a thousand bucks
bow and branch sheets are only a couple
of hundred bucks now that may sound
expensive it is not for something you
are sleeping on every night and they are
really tremendous they hold up in the
wash as well bull and branch comm
promote code Ben get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets Bo LLM branch comm
promo code Ben check it out right now
bull and branch comm promo Club Ben get
that 50 bucks off and lets them know
that we sent you as well okay so a few
more thoughts on on Paul Ryan and and
his exit so again Ryan's priorities were
never backed by by Trump or his fellow
legislators so before judging Ryan
he could pass him what he couldn't have
to look at the caucus right he is only
the head of the caucus if you're the
head of a caucus that looked like Mark
Meadows where everybody was mark Meadows
there everybody where Jim Jim Jordan
then they'd be passing different
legislation but the job of the speaker
is to put all of those various
components together and very often he
was able to do that it's just that the
Senate never passed any of that stuff
okay so all of this bodes very ill for
Republicans obviously going into 2018
and beyond the polls show that there's
gonna be a historic youth wave coming in
2018 according to Harvard you Harvard
University Institute of Politics
this wave of voters 18 to 29 is going to
be very strong 53% probably or
definitely will be voting and of those
most likely to vote 55 percent lean
Democratic 21% favor Republicans at this
points that is a massive imbalance
particularly among young voters who are
going to show up in real big numbers
coming up in in November plus if you
look at the generic ballots right now
the generic ballots do not look good the
generic ballots for Republicans the
average the RealClearPolitics polling
average is 7 points and it is growing
again so it had shrunk down to 3 points
in the Quinnipiac poll
April 6 to April 9th and in the last
couple of polls one from Rasmussen and
one from The Economist is backed up to
five and eight points respectively given
all the news surrounding President Trump
I wouldn't be surprised if that blows up
even bigger
it's not going to be a good year for
Republicans just by data it really is
not gonna be a good year for Republicans
and this raises a question about
president Trump so what is President
Trump going to do if he is faced with
let's say Nancy Pelosi in the house so
the good shot is that Nancy Pelosi will
move for impeachment in the house
knowing that it won't pass through the
Senate if that is the best shot here
there's gonna be a bunch of
investigations it'll be investigations
from here until the end of time and
President Trump will be dragged through
the mud so for all of the hatred of the
Republican Party that a lot of people
are evidencing inside the conservative
movement recognize that if you like
Trump and you're frustrated with the
Republican Party then your worst move
here your worst move is to allow
Democrats to take over the house they'll
do nothing but be a thorn in the side
for president Trump no question okay and
if you don't like President Trump and
you're a conservative then you should
recognize that you need a conservative
Congress because the worst thing that
could happen here is Nancy Pelosi takes
over the house and Chuck Schumer takes
over the Senate and then both of them
are negotiating with President Ron
President Trump who sees himself as a
great deal maker you could easily see
him walk
through the front doors of the of the
White House arm and arm with Pelosi and
Schumer passing a bunch of leftist
priorities because Trump wants to be
seen as a guy who signs things we need a
Republican Congress the fact that we are
unlikely to get one is deeply disturbing
and and really really troubling okay so
I have a few more thoughts on this also
I do want to talk about the continuation
of the Trump investigation and so let's
jump into the the Trump investigation
because there are some breaking pieces
of news with regard to that so first of
all Ellen Dershowitz has come out and he
says that targeting Trump's lawyer
should worry everybody so as you recall
back on Monday the recall back on Monday
President Trump's personal lawyer's
office was raided by the FBI and Alan
Dershowitz has a piece over at the hill
about this he says there's much
speculation as to the significance of
the search of the offices in hotel room
of president Trump's lawyer Michael Kohn
to obtain a search warrant prosecutors
must demonstrate to a judge they have
probable cause to believe the premises
to be searched contain evidence of crime
and must also specify the area to be
searched the items to be seized and in
search of computers the word searches to
be used at least that's the
constitutional requirement in theory
especially where the Sixth Amendment
right to counsel is involved in
additional to the general Fourth
Amendment right against unreasonable
searches but he says that the firewalls
and the so-called tinct teams which were
supposed to prevent the FBI from looking
at documents that they're not supposed
to look at right that these have
experienced troubles in the past he says
it's an imperfect protection of
important constitutional rights he says
that's why Justice Department officials
must be careful to limit the searching
of lawyers offices to compelling cases
involving serious crimes we don't know
at this point what the prosecutors are
looking for but if it relates to
payments made to porn star stormy
Daniels that would not seem to justify
so potentially intrusive a search of
Cohen's confidential lawyer client files
so intertia wits is defending President
Trump he's been defending him on legal
grounds for a while here suggesting that
President Trump has been unfairly
targeted which I think in large measure
he has but all of this is is leading to
you know a serious crisis in inside
American government there's a lot of
talk today about whether President Trump
is actually going to go ahead and fire
robert muller or whether he's going to
fire rod rosen see and those are the two
rumors that are on the table so firing
Muller by the way would not stop the
investigation into Cohen's office
recognize that that was referred out to
the US Attorney's Office in the Southern
Miss
of New York so that's no longer under
Robert Moeller's purview so president
from could fire Mueller it would have no
impact on that he'll just on the Russian
collusion investigation which by most
accounts at this point is turning out to
be sort of an empty bag at least so far
as quote-unquote getting Trump there's
no evidence at this point that there was
serious collusion between the Trump
campaign and anyone in the Russian
government the only people who have been
indicted have been indicted for lying to
the FBI people like George papadopolis
Connor Paige still has not been indicted
despite the FISA warrant against him and
so you know Trump's drive to to fire
Miller I think would be misplaced I
think that that's probably a waste of
time apparently according to a New York
Times piece the president was so furious
after seeing news about subpoenas issued
by the special counsel a few months back
that he told advisers in no uncertain
terms that mr. Miller's investigation
had to be shut down this is when when
Miller was going after Deutsche Bank and
you know so Trump has repeatedly been
considering firing Muller he said the
other day that he was still considering
firing Miller obviously that is
something that he is considering now
apparently he's considering firing rod
Rosenstein rod Rosenstein is of course
the a who oversees Muller and oversees
the rest of the the Department of
Justice with regards to some of these
Trump related investigations so CNN was
reporting that the president's interest
in releasing the Deputy Attorney General
was heightened after the office of his
personal lawyer Michael Kohn was raided
by the FBI the CNN report noted that
such a move could limit special counsel
Robert Muller is quickly escalating
investigation into Trump and Russia but
that of course would not stop what's
going on in the Southern District of New
York
obviously Trump has been very very
critical of rod Rosenstein to this point
the investigation I think is outside of
trumps capacity to contain it at this
point through firings and I think
frankly that would be a mistake for him
to issue these firings if it turns out
that these offices come up with nothing
there'll be plenty of people who defend
him myself included I've been defending
him on the Russian collusion stuff for
well over a year now when it comes to
the the Michael Kohn issue there are
going to be two issues involved one is
was there any actual criminal activity
in twos does it rise to the level of the
impeachable these are two separate
questions and they're not the same
question because it is quite possible
that the President of the United States
was involved in a campaign finance
violation that's possible I don't think
it's I don't think it's out of the realm
of possibility by any stretch of the
imagination but does that rise to the
level of a high crime and misdemeanors
subject to impeachment a little harder
to make
case simply because this was a a
$130,000 payment that violated campaign
finance and Barack Obama's 2008 election
cycle contains two million dollars in
such campaign violations nobody was
impeached over that so unless President
Trump as president of the United States
was actively involved in a conspiracy to
cover up a campaign finance violation
then I think it's gonna be hard to claim
impeachment even if it turns out that
Michael Cohen is guilty of violating
campaign finance laws so that's the
latest in the in in that investigation I
want to get to Mark Zuckerberg
here in just a second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
movement so movement doesn't just you
watch us anymore so first of all
movements watches are just fantastic I
mean I'll start there look at this watch
it's just beautiful right it's it's
simply designed is really classy it's
it's really durable as I say my my son
beats the crap out of it and it's
totally fine to go immediately so check
out their watches but it's not just
movement watches they now have fantastic
sunglasses so I have a pair of movement
sunglasses that they are spectacular my
wife has a really nice pair of movement
sunglasses well she also has a movement
watch all of their stuff is just great
and here's the problem with sunglasses
what happens is that you have two
choices right you can either get a cheap
pair that looks really crappy or you can
get a $200 pair and you feel like you
got ripped off well our friends at
movement said ya know we're not gonna do
that anymore instead they're going to
give you fantastic sunglasses they're
acetates they are not plastic that are
polarized you can get them polarized and
they start at just 70 dollars these are
my go to shades and again they look
great I was riding around in San Diego
the other day on a bicycle with my wife
and I was feeling snazzy because I was
wearing my movement sunglasses
so is she if they had children I would
get them for my kids as well they're
high quality premium acetate frames no
cheap plastic around here check them out
they have a multiplicity of styles get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to movement comm
MVM t-dot-com slash Ben okay that's MVM
t comm slash appear o m BM t comm slash
repair you get 15% off today again these
are the folks who make great watches now
they make fantastic sunglasses as well
it's MVM t.com slash up hero m vm t comm
slash apparel get 15% off today with
free shipping and free returns go join
the movement
MVM t comm slash up hero that also lets
them know that we sent you as well okay
so the other big news on Capitol Hill
aside from the ouster of Paul
aside from the continuing investigation
into the personal lawyer of the
President of the United States as if you
didn't have enough news Mark Zuckerberg
was on the hill yesterday so Mark
Zuckerberg had been called onto the hill
yesterday because of all of the claims
that privacy had been violated by
Facebook that if you publicly post
information and then that information
was scraped by an outside company
meaning that they were using that data
in order to market to you or in order to
generate voter profiles for example by
Cambridge analytical that this was some
sort of terrible evil crime now I think
there are lots of problems in social
media
I really do I've been highly critical of
social media many times and I will be
again in just a moment but if you really
think that the big problem on Facebook
is that you publicly post information
then companies look at it you're stupid
okay you're dumb and if you think the
big problem on Facebook is that tons of
people were being manipulated by fake
news if you really think like Democrats
think that Hillary Clinton would have
won except for these seven ads run by
Russian bots in the 2016 election you
crazy
hey you're out of your mind when people
are so crazy now that there is a big
story that came out of things from NBC
News yesterday about a video that was
viewed about 250,000 times as a supposed
sex tape including Hillary Clinton it
was a fake news obviously because number
one who would ever want to see any of
that on camera but number two is that
really liked was that shifting votes
because we're five minutes away from
Dianne Feinstein calling the head of
pornhub up to the hill to explain why
Hillary Clinton law since there was a
distribution on pornhub of fake Hillary
Clinton's sex tape yeah hey all of this
is nonsense the real problems with
social media is that social media are
now playing a gatekeeper function they
were not meant to play social media
we're supposed to be like a phone line
they're supposed to be a platform hey
here's the way that this works when you
pick up the phone and you call somebody
what is said over that phone line is not
the responsibility of Verizon or AT&T or
Sprint okay it is the responsibility of
the person on the phone Facebook was
supposed to be more like the phone line
it was just a platform you put your
information up there you put your news
stories up there people can engage they
cannot engage it's their free choice
instead Facebook has now interposed
itself between its own users and
information that people want to see
there's been a pet peeve of mine for a
long time they were doing it back in
2016 when they were talking about
shifting their algorithms so that
certain trending topics were not allowed
to trend conservative trending topics
we're not allowed to trend on Facebook
and now of course they
shifted their algorithms to supposedly
benefit local news and and established
mainstream media outlets and against
alternative news sources like Daily wire
right this is why if you're watching
this show right now you're wondering
where your daily wire updates winds you
need to go and check out your own
settings right now and reset your
settings because Facebook has Platt has
tacitly and and without your permission
gone and change the algorithm so that
you are not seeing our updates anymore
because they say that our new site is
somehow not as credible as CNN or the
New York Times which is just absurd a
Facebook right now is even burying which
outlets it's punishing so the so
Facebook is obviously penalizing certain
outlets but it's not explaining what
exactly is penalizing according to tech
website the outline conservative and
right-wing publishers were hit hardest
by the new algorithm change Valley the
engagement numbers of most predominantly
liberal publishers remained unaffected
and now Peter Hasson of The Daily Caller
is reporting that Facebook does not
intend to identify which media outlets
it helps in which it hurts according to
a company spokesperson who spoke to the
Daily Caller News Foundation the
spokesperson argued that if the company
revealed that data it would not give
people a clear picture of Facebook
adding we've made changes to newsfeed to
help people meaningfully connect with
friends and family first
this means public pages of all types are
going to experience declines across
Facebook political pages and partisan
news pages like other public pages have
experienced declines but there are
examples of declines across the
political spectrum except for the fact
that that's not true except for the fact
that if you look at the mainstream media
outlets they have not lost engagements
right the only sites that are losing
engagement are particularly conservative
ones so all of the senators yesterday
we're grilling Mark Zuckerberg on Hill
they're grilling him again today and
first of all it is important to note if
you're gonna have people grill Mark
Zuckerberg they have to have once used a
computer a a lot of these questions look
like they were submitted by my 93 year
old grandmother it was it was a bunch of
people who are asking Mark Zuckerberg
about it but the questions basically the
exchange sounded something like this you
know senator senator Orrin Hatch who's
8,000 years old either reading off a
piece of paper written by a 23 year old
or asking questions that have nothing to
do with facebook or senator dick durbin
who's a complete idiot who probably has
never used facebook sitting there and
saying so Mark Zuckerberg you have a
book full of faces and then Mark
Zuckerberg looking at him in
in in wonderment and amusement this is
what happens when the average age of the
senators who are questioning Mark
Zuckerberg is 57 years old that's not a
rip on people who are 57 it is to say
that the chances that they are really
fluent in social media is pretty low and
that's why you see stupidities like dick
Durbin asking Mark Zuckerberg where he
stayed at his hotel last night there's a
thing that actually happened thank you
very much mr. chairman mr. Zuckerberg
would you be comfortable sharing with us
the name of the hotel you stayed in last
night no okay and this is one of the
things that's so incredibly stupid so
when one of one of the the complaints by
Democrats has been that if you publicly
post information then people see that
information it's a violation of privacy
if Mark Zuckerberg would not have to
under Facebook's rule reveal where he
went to his hotel last night and so I'm
not sure what dick durbin is even
getting a particular man doesn't know
the hell he's talking about there were a
couple of people who actually went after
Zuckerberg on matters that actually do
matter okay so they're really a couple
of matters that are really serious one
is the amount of political bias at
Facebook the the political bias of the
people who are actually implementing and
writing the algorithms and the other
thing that's really important is whether
there is whether whether Facebook is a
platform or whether Facebook is a
publisher and that matters because
getting back to our AT&T Sprint Verizon
discussion if the phone company starts
acting like a censor if they start
buzzing out what you're saying your
friends they become responsible for what
you say to your friends they're actually
like a publisher like we a Daily wire we
edit all of our pieces we purchase all
of our photos from a service called
Getty Images so they're all licensed
because we're a publisher and we're
responsible for the content we post if
however the if if we use a particular
internet service that internet service
is not responsible for the content we
post it's just a platform Facebook has
presented itself as a platform which
means they're not legally responsible
for for example misuse of copyrighted
content or slander but if they are
responsible for what's being put up if
they're controlling what you see and
what you hear then suddenly they need to
be treated like any other news outlet
they need to be treated like NBC or
MSNBC or CBS or CNN or the New York
Times or The Daily wire right so those
are two separate questions when was the
political bias and one was the the fact
that face
is playing sensor which would actually
subject them to liability both of these
lines of questioning were engaged in by
Republicans and these were the only two
lines of questioning that mattered so
the first line of questioning about the
political bias about Facebook cracking
down on conservatives this was pushed by
senator Ted Cruz from Texas and full
disclosure when when senator Cruz
visited our offices and I interviewed
him we had a pretty substantial
discussion about exactly this topic so
good for senator Cruz were going after
Mark Zuckerberg on this here is here
senator Cruz illuminating the issue for
Zuckerberg well mr. Zuckerberg I will
say there are great many Americans who I
think are deeply concerned that that
Facebook and other tech companies are
engaged in a pervasive pattern of bias
and political censorship there have been
numerous instances with Facebook in May
of 2016 Gizmodo reported that Facebook
had purposely and routinely suppressed
conservative stories from trending news
including stories about CPAC including
stories about Mitt Romney including
stories about the Lois Lerner IRS
scandal including stories about Glenn
Beck in addition to that Facebook has
initially shut down the chick-fil-a
Appreciation Day page has blocked a post
of Fox News reporter has blocked over
two dozen catholic pages and most
recently blocked Trump supporters
diamond and silks page with 1.2 million
Facebook followers after determining
their content and brand were quote
unsafe to the community to a great many
Americans that appears to be a pervasive
pattern of political bias do you agree
with that assessment
Zuckerberg would go on to basically say
that it is fair to say that Silicon
Valley is far left-leaning and that
suspicions of political bias are not
unwarranted so he basically admitted
that so that's that's important also it
is important to know along the same
lines that Zuckerberg who is now
proclaiming that Facebook ought to be
the arbiter of what constitutes a good
speech and bad speech can't define what
good speech and bad speech are so he was
questioned by Ben Sasse about
specifically this and he was asked about
defining hate speech because he said
well let's just get rid of all hate
speech let's let's get rid of all the
bad speech and SAS said okay well it's
one thing if you're talking about
violent speech but if you're talking
about nonviolent speech do you even know
how to define that if you claim that
your platform if you claim that you're
not a publisher your platform then how
can you define what speech is hateful
and which speech is not given the fact
that you have no hard considerations as
to what that constitutes so we'll show
you what will we'll play you that audio
in just a second trade that video in
just a second but first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at keeps so
fellas you think you're not losing your
hair but very soon you will I mean the
chances that you're gonna keep all your
hair as you get older very very low and
keeps is the way you can keep your hair
it's the easiest way to keep it they
offer the only two hair loss products
that are clinically proven to keep the
hair that you have you can sign up in
less than five minutes it's entirely
online keeps and it's only ten bucks to
thirty bucks at thirty five bucks a
month so a buck a day on average which
is about half what you typically pay at
the pharmacy
getting started with keeps is actually
pretty easy answer a few questions and
you snap some photos and then a licensed
doctor remotely reviews your information
and gives you the right prescription all
without ever leaving your couch within
two to three days a three-month supply
of your treatment will arrive perfectly
packaged at your door so stop hair loss
today the easy way with keeps offering
customized treatment plans with the only
clinically proven hair loss products for
about a buck a day from the comfort of
your couch receive your first month of
treatment for free go to keep us calm
slash men that's ke EPS calm slash man I
highly recommend it male pattern
baldness runs in my family so I've
spoken with the folks over it keeps ke
EPS calm / Ben that's a free month of
treatment and keeps calm / Ben keeps
hair today hair tomorrow again use that
slash pen so that they know that we sent
you and receive your first month of
treatment for free keeps calm / Ben ke
EPS calm / Ben okay so we're gonna get
two more of Mark Zuckerberg being ripped
up and down by the Republicans in the
Senate Judiciary Committee in just
second but for the rest we're gonna have
to go over to Daily wire and subscribe
so for $9.99 a month you get the rest of
my show live the rest of Noel's show
live the rest of clay vans show live you
get to be part of our mailbag which will
be doing on Friday it feels like it
should be a Friday it however is not
which means you have a couple of days to
get your questions in right now and if
you want to ask us questions live on air
you can do that as well on Friday
because you can watch the show log into
daily wire and just go to the chatroom
and ask a bunch of questions and we'll
answer them as they come in here it's
daily wire if you want all of those
things plus the greatest in all beverage
vessels this right here the leftist here
is hot or cold tumblr check it out for
99 bucks a year again we we
we always suggest that you get to
membership again a lot of letters from
people saying how can we help get a
membership that's that's really the
cheap way you can help because that
ensures that we can pay the bills and
continue to bring you our top-notch
content if you just want to listen later
for free
then please go over to iTunes SoundCloud
YouTube please subscribe please leave us
review we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so senator Cruz ripped Zuckerberg up and
down on his level of political bias at
Facebook which is well worth while and
then and then he is Zuckerberg his
question about how he's policing speech
because this is really the danger and
this is what Democrats want you have to
understand the entire Democratic crusade
against these so-called privacy
violations of Facebook is really an
attempt by Democrats to grab control of
the reigns of Facebook and drive
Facebook to please them politically
right the implicit promise here is that
a face book starts mirroring all the
Democratic talking points then they will
stop regulating them or threatening to
do so that's what they're talking about
that's really what all this is about
and Zuckerberg already has leanings in
that direction right Zuckerberg so Lefty
he's a Democrat and he's already talked
about how he wants to stop hate speech
on his platform but as is obvious he has
no idea how to find hate speech because
there is no way to define hate speech in
any real way you may decide or Facebook
may decide it needs to police a whole
bunch of speech that I think America
might be better off not having policed
by one company that has a really big and
powerful platform can you define hate
speech senator I think that this is a
really hard question and I think it's
one of the reasons why we struggle with
it there are certain definitions that
that we that we have around you know
calling for for violence or let's just
agree on that if somebody's gone for
violence
we that shouldn't be there okay so again
there is a difference between saying
you're gonna ban speech that calls for
violence and singing in a band hate
speech Zuckerberg has no idea he's
talking about he says that AI is gonna
be able to do is going to be able to
identify hate speech that's nonsense
yeah what we're talking about here is
social media platforms acting as sensors
and that's really the point okay
Zuckerberg made a pretty shocking
admission in the middle of this in the
middle of this colloquy with with the
Republican senators he was asked
specifically are you a platform or are
you go publisher and he basically admits
were a publisher you agree now that
Facebook and those other social media
platforms are not neutral platforms but
bear some responsibility for the content
I agree that we're responsible for the
content okay so as soon as he says that
his lawyers in Silicon Valley lose their
minds because he just acknowledged that
Facebook now ought to be treated like
Daily wire or the New York Times meaning
that any unlicensed photo shared on
Facebook makes Facebook suable it means
that any piece of slander published on
Facebook makes Facebook suable hey this
is the choice Mark Zuckerberg has and
he's gonna have to make it are you a
platform or are you in fact publisher
hey Dan Sullivan the senator from Alaska
he says to talk he asked Zuckerberg the
same question you'll see Zuckerberg
start to back off because there was a
little break and the in the questioning
I'm sure you got a call from his lawyer
saying mark you need to back off that
one real quick
so here's Dan Sullivan questioning
Zuckerberg when you mentioned the center
coordinate Cornyn I you said you are
responsible for your content so which
are you are you a tech company are you
the world's largest publisher because I
think that goes to a really important
question on what form of regulation or
government action if any you would take
senator this is a a really big question
I I view us as a tech company because
the primary thing that we do is build
technology and broad you're responsible
for your content which make exactly nine
of a publisher right well I agree that
we're responsible for the content but we
don't produce the content I think that
when people ask us if we're a media
company or a publisher my understanding
of what the heart of what they're really
getting at is do we feel responsibility
for the content on our platform the
answer to that I think is clearly yes
and but I don't think that that's
incompatible with fundamentally yet at
our core being a technology company were
the main thing that we do is have
engineers and build products yeah his
lawyers have got to just be twisting
themselves and pretzels over all of this
because he just opened themselves he
just opened up Facebook's have millions
of dollars in liability if you are
here's the way it works now if you're a
photographer and some idiot in Utah post
your photo without without paying you
without licensing it normally you'd have
to sue the idiot in Utah you couldn't
sue Facebook Mark Zuckerberg just said
we feel responsibility for the content
that's posted on Facebook which means
that you can now sue Facebook okay
Facebook is a much deeper pocket under
the Digital Millennium Copyright Act
there's an automatic statutory penalty
for use for unlicensed use of materials
like that that ranges from $750 per
instance to $30,000 per instance how
many unlicensed photos are posted on
Facebook every minute my goodness if his
lawyers are not in a state of panic
now then they really should be because I
promise you the lawsuits are forthcoming
and they are forthcoming in pretty short
order it's just it's amazing but this is
where the Democrats have driven
Zuckerberg and when you decide to go for
leftist and censor your own content and
censor contents of other people because
you want to please you're a cocktail
party friends that has some pretty
significant ramifications for your
business as well okay so in other silly
news okay I just have to bring you a
couple of really dumb stories because
they are pretty amazing this one is from
Boston the Boston Marathon has now
declared they've finally publicly
acknowledged their new policies
regarding gender according to Daily wire
James Baird over the Daily wire they say
that men who identify as women can
compete against biological women
regardless of whether or not they have
taken any steps to officially transition
so according to Boston Athletic
Association president Tom grill quote we
take people at their word we register
people as they specify themselves to be
those registering do not have to provide
any sort of proof that they are in fact
in any sort of transition state
medically as required by the Olympics in
many professional sports members of the
LGBT community have had to deal with a
lot over the years and we'd rather not
add to that burden says grow that's an
amazing statement they've had to deal
with a lot over the years and we don't
want to add to the burden it's not a
burden to suggest that men should not be
competing against women in the women's
bracket if the n-c-double-a applied the
same logic to basketball you know how
you know first of all everybody be able
to dunk in the W in the in the women's
n-c-double-a but second of all there'd
be no way to prevent 7-foot dudes from
saying that they were ladies and then
just being in the and just competing as
women or even if they were transgender
7-foot dudes with twice the upper body
mass of women competing against women I
mean this isn't fair to women it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous and women
should be insulted by this okay forget
about it it's a liberal it's such a
leftist trope that if you've dealt with
a lot over the years the rules no longer
apply to you right that members of the
LGBT community have had to deal with a
lot over the years agree we'd rather not
add to that burden again it's not a
burden to say you need to play by the
rules this is ridiculous
so ABC features one man who identifies
as a woman who admits to not having
undergone any treatment to lower
testosterone
which allows men to have significant
athletic advantage over women Stevie
Romer is a transgender woman from
Woodstock Illinois and says she
registered the scoring ABC News for
Boston as a woman because that's what
she is although she hasn't done anything
lower her testosterone levels Romer
legally changed her gender grew her hair
out and started living openly as a woman
more than a year ago
to be able to experience experience it
as me was really really important she
said I've been a runner since as long as
I can remember I love running but I just
happened to be transgender okay so then
how about this how bout we just get rid
of both gender categories right there
won't be any sex categories for the
marathon at all and women will never win
my biological women will never win a
marathon ever in history because men are
faster than women on average but
apparently I guess men will be winning
the women's marathon anyways we may as
well just obliterate the categories I
mean it the the the failure to
distinguish between sex and gender is
clearly an incredible thing and the fact
that so many in the scientific community
have pretended to buy into this and I
say pretend because they do know better
there's not a doctor alive in the United
States who does not know the difference
between a man and a woman biologically
and yet they act as though these
distinctions mean nothing when it comes
to real-world consequences as long as
the man believes his woman or vice versa
ABC quoted a doctor from a boston-based
LGBT health & Advocacy Center who
insists there is quote no physiologic
advantage to being assigned male at
birth what in the world there's no
physiological to being assigned first of
all you're not assigned male at birth
okay it's not like you come out
genderless it's not like you come out
and you're just a ball of human flesh
without a penis or a vagina and with no
chromosomal z' and with no chromosomal
description get some surd it's absurd
you're not assigned your sex at birth
kind of stupidity is this okay but the I
guess now we have to subjectively just
dismiss science outright it's an amazing
amazing thing again none of this is true
LIVESTRONG suggests that men outperform
women by about 10 percent across all
athletic events the gender gap and
athletic performance is shown in records
from Olympic competition has remained
stable since 1983 the mean difference
has been about 10% between men and women
for all events the mean gap is 10 point
7 percent for running eight point nine
percent for swimming and seventeen point
five percent for jumping that doesn't
even take into account lifting where
it's significantly greater when
performance has improved the
improvements are proportional for each
gender David Epstein author of the
sports gene discussed the biological
realities of athletic differences
between genders in a piece for The
Washington Post in 2014 and in it he
provided some background on women's
inclusion in several sports which led to
a momentary explosion in their
performance that ultimately Plateau
in terms of top speed and a range of
running events women began leveling off
by the 1980s and the records stagnated
after the crackdown on mega doping of
female athletes from some Eastern Bloc
nations from the 100 meters to the
10,000 meters they gap between elite
male and female performers it generally
stands around 11% at the pro level that
is a chasm the women's 100 record would
have been too slow by a quarter second
to qualify for entry into the men's
field at the 2012 Olympics okay so again
the fact that we are now shifting
objective standards to meet subjective
realities is just insane insane on every
level okay time for some things I like
and then some things I hate and then I
have a little bit of Bible for you so
things that I like today so we've been
doing musicals that you may not know
there's a musical called promises
promises based on the fantastic Billy
Wilder film the apartment from 1960 I
believe that was one of our very first
recommendations on things I like here
the here at the ben shapiro show but
this is based on that movie the plot of
the movies basically there's a guy who
falls in love with a girl he also has he
used he allows executives at his company
to use his apartment as basically a a
love nest for their affairs and the girl
that he falls in love with has been
having an affair with one of the
executives at the company that's that's
the essential set up for the plot the
the musical is quite good all the music
was written by Burt Bacharach you'll
remember Burt Bacharach from such thing
as from such things as the songs and
Butch Cassidy right raindrops keep
falling on my habits Burt bet Burt
Bacharach but the music and promises
promises is a little bit less elevator
music music II then then in some of back
racks other stuff the the script to the
book was written by a Neil Simon it's a
very good musical it lost a seventeen
seventy-six at the Tonys which is
fitting but it's a good musical Jerry
Orbach who you're going to hear hear and
see here at Jerry Orbach who is playing
the main who's playing the main male
lead here you'll remember him from Law &
Order right he's he's one of the guys
he's letting Lennie in Law & Order and
he is also he's also the voice of the of
lumière in the original animated Beauty
and the Beast and so here he is singing
the song she likes basketball from
promises promises
[Music]
of basketball she likes basketball above
that I have someplace to take her when
we go out basketball
whoever wouldn't read never would have
thought that my favorite girl liked my
favorite sport like any other kid I
would make believe with my hand
[Music]
they did uh they did a revival of this
musical I believe in 2017 starring Sean
Hayes I've heard them do this number
it's not bad actually which is kind of
surprising because I don't know I could
sing it's amazing how many guys who are
big stars now actually consume
mic JK Simmons you know the guy who just
won an Oscar a couple of years ago for
whiplash JK Simmons actually not only
can he sing he was actually in the
revival of Guys and Dolls he played one
of the the tinhorn the one of the
tinhorn gamblers so is it's interesting
how many of these folks can actually
sing it here's here's an odd one go back
and watch the animated Pocahontas Mel
Gibson plays the role of of John Smith
in the animated Pocahontas who sings for
Mel Gibson in that Mel Gibson Mel Gibson
can actually sing really it's kind of
amazing how many of these stars actually
can hold it to okay time for a couple of
things that I hate so one of the things
that I really dislike as a general
matter is hypocrisy and one of the
things that I find hilarious is how many
Democrats are now suggesting that
President Trump does not have the
authority to attack Syria
it's an amazing thing because I sort of
agree that it's Congress's job to
determine where when war has been
declared right that's the that's how the
powers are delegated under the
Constitution but Democrats don't have a
lot of room to a lot of ground to stand
on considering that Barack Obama
declared about 33 Wars without any sort
of congressional involvement at all Tim
Kaine who you recall was the most boring
VP candidate in the history of mankind
he ran with Hillary Clinton and he said
that President Trump has no authority to
attack the Syrian government whatsoever
Senator Jeff Flake and I have had a
bipartisan authorization focusing upon
all of the military action we're
currently taking against non-state
actors the president currently does not
have any legal authority to wage war
against nation states missile strikes
against Syria for example without coming
to Congress yeah all of that is true
where were you Tim came when Barack
Obama was bombing Libya but where were
you where was the Express authorization
to bomb Libya and kill Muammar Qaddafi
there wasn't any obviously okay other
things that I hate one of the things
that's been so amazing is watching as
the left turn
rock obama into this highfalutin figure
who doesn't do who really you know was
it was above the fray really above the
fray who's just a beautiful man who
never really had the capacity to deign
to the to the pub today to talk to the
public on their own level just a man who
elevated the public discourse well it's
now coming out according to The Daily
Mail that an Obama aide has revealed how
he was a groupie president who fawned
over celeb
and was steamed celebs and was steamed
when a high school coach called his wife
fat but Michelle and also favored extra
tight sweatpants and white socks with
sandals so the last part I don't care
about I don't care about how he felt
about people who insult his wife I'm
fine with that you should be angry at
people who insult your wife as a general
rule but it is true that the Obamas were
obsessed with celebrity right Bruce
Springsteen George Clooney Leonardo
DiCaprio were among a bunch of the stars
who came to the White House to hang out
with the cool president now you know one
of the things that's fun for me is I've
had a chance to meet a lot of
celebrities in my job and the
celebrities who are actually interesting
to me are the ones who you don't
actually know about they are they're the
ones who are the writers and directors
of films but you've never heard of them
actors tend to be really uninteresting
as a general rule people who are
musicians who are stars they tend to be
really uninteresting as a general rule
but Obama was in fact obsessed with
celebrities and Obama was a celebrity to
the Hollywood crowd one of the reasons
you got a reality to be present in
President Trump is because he was not
actually the first reality TV president
the first reality TV president was in
fact Barack Obama who spent enormous
sums of time talking to all of his
Hollywood buddies and occupying a
central place on our television screens
just the way a reality star would this
is why he was he was doing interviews
with pimp with a limp and and with an
glozell right that the president before
Donald Trump certainly was not averse to
to the little red light on the camera
okay so time for a quick quick Bible
review so I wanted to talk a little bit
about this section from the book of
Samuel so this is First Samuel chapter
15 19 through 32 and this is the section
in which Samuel deprives Saul of the
kingship so Saul is one of the great
tragic figures in all of world
literature
when you look at Saul as the King he
didn't want to be the king in the first
place he's appointed the king and he's a
pretty good King but he is not
self-confident and he's constantly going
to the people for approval and so
there's this real
fascinating section where he is ordered
by God to slay all the Amalekites and he
doesn't write he keeps some of them
alive he keeps some of their animals
alive and Samuel who's a prophet
approaches him he says why did you not
obey the Lord
why did you pounce on the plunder and do
evil in the eyes of the Lord and Saul
says but I did obey the Lord I went on
the mission the Lord assigned me I
completely destroyed the Amalekites and
brought back a dog their king the
soldiers took sheep and cattle from the
plunder the best of what was devoted to
God in order to sacrifice them to the
Lord your God at Gilgal so first of all
you can see you've got a problem already
he's saying the Lord your God writes not
the Lord my God at Gilgal it's the Lord
your God so already Saul was separating
himself off from the from the God of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob that he is
supposed to be subject to Samuel replies
does the Lord delight in burnt offerings
and sacrifices as much as an obeying the
Lord to obey is better than sacrifice
and to heed is better than the fat of
rams rebellion is like the sin of
divination and arrogance is like the
evil of idolatry because you have
rejected the word of the Lord he is
rejected he was king when Saul says to
Samuel I've sinned I violated the Lord's
command and your instructions I was
afraid of the men and so I gave in to
them now I beg you forgive my sin and
come back with me so I may worship the
Lord and Samuel says to him I'm not
going to go back to you you have
rejected the word of the Lord and the
Lord has rejected you as king over
Israel eventually Saul ends up bringing
agog in front of Samuel and and Samuel
ends up slaying a dog instead of Saul so
what's interesting about this is that if
you look at King David right Kings David
maintains the kingship after he is
threatened with its removal by Nathan
the Prophet and what David did is a lot
worse than what salted in any objective
sense of morality right King David
impregnated another man's wife and then
sent that guy to die at the battlefield
right that's pretty horrifying and
Nathan approaches him and says and says
you just violated God's law and and
David repents right this is why when
people compare Trump to David you have
to take into account the fact that David
repents David gets to keep his job why
because his sin was out of his sin was
out of passion it was not out of willful
disobedience to God on behalf of the
people so this is I think a really
fascinating thing to remember when it
comes to our daily politics you'll
virtue and virtue is about adherence to
some sort of higher principle some sort
of higher morality believe in God or not
believe in God being a good person is
about being subject to higher principles
in higher virtue not just the will of
the people the way that's all governed
and the reason
couldn't be the king is because Saul
spent a lot of his time with one eye on
the people one of the people want me to
do one of the people say I should do the
people want to keep the animals well I
guess I'll just obey God and I'll keep
the animals this is why he's deprived of
the kingship and David is not David sins
for sure and David does some really
awful things but at no point does he say
you know what the will of the people
Trump's what I know to be right and
virtuous or what God has instructed me
to do and no point does he say that and
that's the reals of finding feature and
there's something we should all remember
because it's easy enough to say yeah
most people suck most people are ok with
this or that most people want me to do X
but that does not justify the doing of X
you have to make an explicit argument as
to why it is right to do X Y or Z you
can't just rely on populism to justify
your own your own malfeasance ok we'll
be back here tomorrow with whatever
crazy news breaks then I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018